bonjour à tous je vous ai parlé il ya
pas très longtemps dû aux nordistes qui
honorera présenté il ya pas très
longtemps dans la question maintenant
qui se pose c'est est ce qu'il faut
attendre le ordis ou est-ce qu'il faut
acheter le honor view 10 quel est le
modèle le plus intéressant entre les
deux est ce que ceux qui ont view 10
sont un peu floués par rapport aux
nordistes qui va sortir on va regarder
ça on va essayer de comparer un petit
peu point par point pour sortir après
une vue globale à savoir quels ou non
racheter entre le view 10 et le dise en
2018 on y va maintenant
le only sortie n'y a pas très longtemps
alors effectivement simple papier le aux
nordistes est vraiment vraiment la date
en tout cas un excellent smartphone mais
pourtant en début d'année est sorti le
interview 10 je vais déjà fait une vidéo
dessus complète pour tester sur view dit
c'est un excellent smartphone pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils honorent sort à 11h10 en
réalité assez proche du haut d'environ
10 qui au final se aux nordistes et
l'évolution du haut noir 9
alors chez au nord il ya beaucoup de
produits qui sortent le cepd a le 7
c'est le 7 6 le saut il y en a de
partout le 9 lite est une gamme une
galerie extrêmement complète chez honor
tellement complète qu'elle devient même
un peu trop complexe c'est pas évident
de s'y repérer un peu là dedans et qui
te comprendre au final quels produits
achetés dans la mesure on va acheter un
produit au nord pour ceux qui ne
seraient pas encore aujourd'hui au nord
est une filiale de huawei honor sont des
produits qui sont vraiment franchement
de bonne qualité sur une entrée de gamme
des produits qui vous à peu près 150
euros aux alentours à peu près sûr du
milieu de gamme et l'ami commence à
flirter relève du flirté vraiment les
chamois que gamondi pas parce qu'il ya
des finitions qui ne sont pas là il ya
des prestations qui ne sont pas encore
là maintenant sur la qualité des
produits sur la puissance sur la qualité
des processeurs on est vraiment sur des
choses qu'on peut retrouver dans les
produits très haut de gamme
effectivement au nord se positionne pas
du tout là dessus pour l'instant se
positionne vraiment sur des produits
milieu de gamme
on a suivi l'évolution 8,8 pro 9
maintenant le au nord 10 mais est-ce
qu'il faut acheter son honneur dit c'est
ça c'est vraiment frustrant lorsqu'on va
faire c'est que je vous ai fait un
comparatif donc on va regarder ça
ensemble entre surtout le au nord 10 et
le honor view disent pas ce que sont
vraiment deux points qui nous intéresse
d'ailleurs à se poser la question à
l'avenir est ce qu'à la fin de l'année
ils vont nous sortir un au nord du vieux
ça pourrait complètement être le cas
quelle est la différence entre la gamme
classique aux ordis au dorner ces
compagnies et la gamme view ça tout de
suite c'est un petit peu difficile à
dire parce qu'on n'a pas vraiment de
visibilité pas beaucoup de recul sur
cette gamme view la gamme you c'est
plutôt ceux des produits qui sont
boostés à l'intelligence artificielle
sauf que on va très bien que depuis lors
neuf notre produit
l' intelligence artificielle se
développe de plus en plus et que c'est
vraiment une volonté de la part de au
nord mali dessus voilà donc je sais ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure en
préambule je trouve qu'il ya vraiment un
mélange quelque chose d'un peu compliqué
il ya beaucoup de produits c'est un
début
pour savoir quels produits au nord a
chuté à moins d'en trouver indirectement
d'aller dessus de pas regarder ce qui à
côté
sinon c'est rapidement un peu le bazar
alors on va regarder déjà d'un point de
vue purement technique essayer de
comprendre ce qu'ils sachent un peu
derrière tout ça parce que du point de
vue de l'écran sur le honor view 10 le
modèle du début d'année vous êtes un
écran 5 99 pouces c'est une dali psc du
lcd une résolution de 2160 parmi 80
pixels la différence que vous avec les
odeurs view 10 alors effectivement on
est sur l'écran qui a un peu plus petit
5.84 tous ses duels tps c'est du scd
résolution de 2280 par 1080 pixels entre
les deux tailles d'écran il n'y a pas
non plus un écart qui est monstrueux à
mon avis la différence elle va surtout
d'un point de vue esthétique sur le
nordiste vous avez une encoche sur le
haut sur le haut review 10 vous n'avez
absolument aucune encoches c'est surtout
là dessus que vraiment se faire le point
de différenciation non pas sur les
capacités techniques du produit est
meilleur d'un côté ou de l'autre mais
surtout sur la différence esthétique
après en dessous de l'écran vous avez
dans les deux cas un capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour venir
déverrouiller et vos smartphones marche
très bien il n'y a pas de souci il ya
aussi une différence du point de vue du
design sur le aux nordistes
vous avez adoré reese et briand ont
trouvé un petit peu sur le au nord 9 sur
le haut review disent vous avez un dôme
at c'est pas tout à fait la même
finition
une fois de plus dans les deux choeurs
et de son très bien maintenant c'est
vraiment une question de goût très
personnel voilà un peu pour les points
différence d'un point de vue esthétique
sur ces deux produits dans les deux cas
vous retrouver le processeur kirin 970
couple est assis giga octet drame
ça fait très bien à faire le kirin 270
vous le retrouvez sur les produits de
huawei les produits haut de gamme c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui marche très
bien
vous aurez vraiment d'excellents
résultats d'un côté comme de l'autre
donc pas vous poser la question en tout
cas de ce point de vue là on peut se
poser la question du point de vue de la
capacité de stockage parce que sur le au
nord disent vous avez soit du 64 giga
soit du sandettie gia qui sont tous les
deux non extensible si vous achetez 64
n'imaginais même pas à rajouter une
carte microsd pour ajouter la capacité
de stockage ce n'est pas possible
à la différence sur le lui dise vous
avez 128 go de stockage mais qui est
extensible bon voilà ça c'est un petit
peu un point de différence quand même
prendre en considération sans souci nous
fait beaucoup de photos beaucoup de
vidéos de photos qui me brûle musique
il faut quand même anticipé ça pour pas
être surpris côté batterie paraît il n'y
a pas grande différence le aux nordistes
à une batterie de trois mille quatre
cent millions père earl eux
younis une batterie de 3750 milan
terreur bon en fait la batterie est due
aux nordistes situe un peu entre les
honneurs 9 qui avait une batterie de
3200 milan terreur et puis l'organisme
une fois de plus je suis pas persuadé
que vous sentiez une grosse différence
son utilisation donc d'un point de vue
performances d'un point de vue batterie
autonomie entre le au nord 10 et le ono
review disent ça devrait être à peu près
la même chose
alors étant coté photo vidéo alors côté
photo vous avez à l'arrière sur le ordis
un capteur 16 mégapixels couleurs avec
une ouverture de f 1.8 donc non
suffisamment lumineux et un capteur 24
mégapixels monochrome en noir et blanc
sur le view disent vous avez un capteur
5 mégapixels toujours couleurs avec une
ouverture également de f 1.8 et un
capteur monochrome de 20 mégapixels
bon je suis pas sûr non plus une grosse
différence qu'il soit là dessus vous
pouvez filmer en 4k d'un côté comme de
l'autre
à l'avant une caméra de celle ci sur le
viol disent de 13 mégapixels et sur le
north nice une caméra de celle fille de
24 mégapixels
ouais voilà de ce point de vue là non
plus je ne suis pas sûr que le nombre de
pixels à échanger vraiment grand chose
alors je n'ai pas d'info sur les
ouvertures même on voit là pour faire
baisser elle fit des choses relativement
classique et standard n'ont pas cherché
dans la grosse définition de la grande
qualité ça fera vraiment la ferme à côté
comme de l'autre
vous avez du bluetooth 7.2 d'un côté
comme de l'autre vous avez un port jack
du côté d'un côté comme de l'autre
vous avez de l'usb type c pour la
recharge d'un côté comme de l'autre de
ne tient pas vraiment points de
différence
le ordis tourne sous un androïde 8.1
oreo avec une surcouche à lui 8 points
tandis que les honneurs younis tourne
sous android 8.0 oreo avec une surcouche
maison em hui 8.0 donc là-dessus il n'y
a pas non plus vraiment de différences
notables au final quand on regarde la
fiche technique il y en a pas un qui se
détache vraiment par rapport à l'autre
alors quelle est la réelle différence à
mon avis le point de différence le plus
important d'autant plus que si vous
allez acheter des produits comme ça vous
n'allez pas chercher la performance la
plus pointue houzel pas chercher le
point de détail de plus pointu parce
qu'on va pas debout sur des produits
haut de gamme à mon sens la différence
rechercher la d'un point de vue
esthétique est ce que c'est encore vous
plaît vous déplaît ans
duo nordiste si vous ne voulez pas
d'encoches aller sur le dos review 10
qui a très très bien s'il encore je vous
déplaît pas ils vous avez effectivement
ce style là vous pouvez aller sur le au
nordiste est ce que vous aimez le doubs
briand est ce que vous préférez le dos
mat
voilà à mon avis c'est un petit peu là
dessus qu'il faut se positionner alors
dites vous bien que si vous avez acheté
un honneur view 10 en début d'année vous
n'avez pas hyper vous ne serez pas déçus
il n'y a absolument aucun intérêt
d'aller vendre votre honneur you dispo
acheter le aux nordistes parce que au
point de détail près c'est sensiblement
la même chose si ce n'est comme je le
disais du point de vue esthétique
par contre si vous avez un au nord huit
pros 1,8 ou des modèles beaucoup plus
bas beaucoup plus ancien des produits
d'autres fabricants et que vous voulez
aller sur ce produit sur le aux
nordistes ou l'audio 10 une fois de plus
vous pouvez y est sans aucun problème
les deux sont vraiment bien si vous avez
un honneur et que vous vous intéressez
de près en tout cas aux nordistes ou
interviews 10 vous pouvez y aller sans
aucun problème mais je vous le dis si
vous avez acheté le hors ue 10 ne vous
sentez pas lésé il vous dit pas j'aurais
dû attendre et acheter les aux nordistes
ça ne sert strictement à rien parce que
les deux produits sont vraiment vraiment
vraiment très très proches
donc ça ne sert strictement à rien
d'autant plus que d'une positionnement
tarifaire
vous êtes un peu dans un mouchoir de
poche alors effectivement alors à la
cage de cette vidéo le nordiste n'a pas
été officialisée en france il va l'être
d'ici à quelques semaines
mais on s'attend vraiment à ce que le
haut nordisk août à quelque chose près
le même tarif que léonore view 10 soyez
rassuré le ordis les honneurs view dit
ce sont deux produits sont vraiment très
similaire de l'intelligence artificielle
d'un côté comme de l'autre avec un qui
rident 970 couple assis giga de ram vous
êtes tranquille pour la reconnaissance
de scène par des photos optimiser ce que
fait les honneurs view 10e ordis le fera
vraiment sensiblement pareil avec une
qualité très correcte donc ne vous
inquiétez pas je sais pas si je vous
aide et j'espère j'espère vous avoir
aidé un petit peu dans tout ça parce que
c'est compliqué des ménages trouve
qu'aujourd'hui chez honore la gale est
tellement complexe que c'est vraiment je
le dis une fois de plus très difficile
de s'y retrouver d'ailleurs je sais pas
s'il ya des personnes de honor qui sont
derrière la regardez moi essayer un
petit peur je sais qu effectivement ça
n'est pas forcément de chez vous ça
vient probablement de chine les têtes
pensantes ceux qui fabriquent les
produits puis le marketing derrière
doigt après un petit peu faire son taf
derrière mais d'un point de vue
marketing se trouve que on a beaucoup de
mal à comprendre vraiment
différence entre tous ces produits alors
un honneur view 10g pour moi c'est très
clair un produit intérieur artificielle
le nouveau produit 2018 le aux nordistes
c'est une évolution mais est ce qu'il y
avait intérêt à sortir un honneur 10
avec un honneur iodice à côté c'est
pareil pour cette a7 cr7 this bed pluie
a tellement dont je me perds un oeuf lie
dans l'offre il y en a tellement que je
sais même plus où on s'y perd la
numérotation la la dénomination des
produits 6e de tellement proches que au
final je ne sais pas lequel acheté et je
me positionne du point de vue
consommateur c'est extrêmement compliqué
de s'y retrouver
donc voilà si à quelqu'un de si au nord
qui regarde cette vidéo fait remonter un
peu l'info c'est pas si ça va changer
grand chose en tout cas je le dis et 10
points de vue consommateur en tout cas
vous prenez pas la tête lui aux
nordistes et les odeurs view
disposez-vous la question du design du
look en règle générale il ya deux
produits sont très bien dites moi si je
vous ai des marques et moi toutes vos
questions toutes vos suggestions tous
vos retours d'expérience en commentaire
comme d'habitude je vous invite à vous
abonner parce qu'on parlait toujours
plus de produits tech quel qu'il soit
lent parle beaucoup de smartphones lors
des temps j'en conviens mais rassurez
vous il ya plein de choses qui vont
arriver puis on va un petit peu ce
diversifier vers beaucoup de surprises
et notamment dès la rentrée des modes
c'est tant mieux rester vraiment
connecté
je vous invite comme d'hab avait cédé
jolie pouces prenez soin de vous
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs et
je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]